another new covet record in the u.s more
than 145 thousand people hospitalized
with the virus still u.s president joe
biden is sounding optimistic i'm
confident we're on the right track thank
you
polls show much of the country disagrees
one problem testing this is boston
and here in missouri long lines to get a
test and results are taking longer to
come back
everywhere we've been it's been a line
like this this is what testing looks
like in most of the country the other
option at home tests but they are
expensive and really hard to find
same with masks the government says
omicron means everyone needs better
masks if you can find and afford them so
some local governments have begun giving
them out i'm just coming to get the mask
i can't find anything in the stuff that
i've done k-95s
they're just so expensive and it takes
two three weeks to get them
at this senate hearing the focus was
supposed to be on how to make it all
better but it often got contentious with
republicans launching personal attacks
on the nation's chief covet advisor who
says he is receiving death threats
because of it so i asked myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so here's the problem case numbers
are extremely high but hospitalizations
usually follow those by about three
weeks and hospitals are already
stretched this one several times has had
to simply tell ambulance drivers don't
come here we are just quite out of beds
the biden administration says they are
ramping up the production of medicines
masks tests but those are weeks maybe
months away and the situation is getting
worse by the day and after saying it
wouldn't be needed authorities admit
they are working on a vaccine for the
omicron variant and working on others
that could work on the next variant that
comes after that omicron is likely not
to be the last curveball this virus
throws at us nearly two years on and
once again hospitals are stretched lives
are being lost and every day new signs
that life is far from returning to
normal
patty culhane al jazeera maryland